San Francisco Chronicle reports that
Oakland is without a police chief again
it's scandal-ridden Police Department
has had three Chiefs and a little more
than one week oakland has a nation's
third-highest violent crime rate Mireya
Villarreal is in Los Angeles with in
Marysville that heads will roll Mariah
good morning well good morning the most
recent chief resigned on Friday just two
days after being on the job as you said
there is no acting police chief in
oakland right now instead the department
is under civilian control we are
hell-bent on rooting out this disgusting
culture in no uncertain terms Oakland's
mayor is vowing to get to the bottom of
the sex scandal rocking the city's
police force I feel that this is an
appropriate time to place civilian
oversight over this Police Department
the department's high-stakes game of
musical chairs started jun 9th when
chief Shawn went abruptly resigned
interim chief Ben Farrow was removed six
days later because of still undisclosed
information that led the mayor to quote
lose confidence in him assistant Chief
Paul Figueroa took over only to resign
two days later it's incredible so
despicable to disgrace I think it
doesn't really speak to Oakland's
character things first began to unravel
in September after an officer killed
himself and left a suicide note claiming
several officers were having sex with a
teenage prostitute the first one at 16
the young woman at the heart of the
scandal who goes by the name Celeste [ __ ]
is cooperating with investigators she
told our station KPIX that looking back
she believes officers took advantage of
her at the time though I was happy to
you know wow you know these men in
uniform getting me protection but now
that I'm a team looking back at it yeah
I do feel I do feel like they did at
least 14 officers are involved in the
sex scandal to have resigned to find out
that my own police officers have engaged
in this despicable behavior it is so
inferior
I'm pretty speechless in addition to the
sex abuse claims there's also a separate
investigation into races text messages
that were sent between officers the
mayor calls these messages hate speech
and says she's doing a full
investigation one officer is already
under administrative leave Nora all
right Maria thank you